bienvenue à bord du sous-marin windsor
l'un des quatre sous marins canadiens
erik isabelle et le commandant second
chaque jour pendant 12 heures je serai
en charge sous marin de 59 personnes
je créerai pour prendre des décisions
que je veux faire au large d'halifax le
vaisseau participent à une simulation de
guerre avec la participation d'un navire
donne hélicoptère et d'un avion
patrouille militaire
les opérations sous-marines hier sont
généralement entourée de secret ce n'est
pas le cas des nombreux problèmes qui
ont infligé six sous-marins
depuis le rachat il ya vingt ans de l'
incendie à bord du sous-marin chicoutimi
en 2004 qui a causé la mort de marins
aux problèmes de corrosion
certains s'y soumaré ont passé une bonne
partie de leur vie utile en cale sèche
la marine canadienne a déclaré six
sous-marins opérationnel en 2015
dix sept ans après leur acquisition il
semble que la flotte
enfin atteint sa vitesse de croisière le
chicoutimi est en mission en asie le
windsor partira en europe en 2018
le milieu 90 le museau pour être smara
qui est performant au niveau de 21e
siècle le windsor s'étaient équipés
récemment d'un système de sonar capable
de détecter les objets sous l'eau à la
fine pointe de la technologie
cette modernisation s'inscrit dans la
politique de défense du gouvernement
libéral qui a pris la décision d'étendre
la vie de ces vaisseaux jusqu'en 2035
une opération qui selon le gouvernement
coûterait au delà d'un milliard et demi
de dollars
un investissement incontournable dans un
contexte de plus en plus instable croit
un expert
nous avons besoin de ces sous-marins
surtout avec le développement des forces
sous-marines hier en chine en russie et
la menace en corée du nord dit il le
gouvernement libéral n'a aucun plan pour
remplacer ces sous-marins vieillissant
une lacune énorme dans la politique de
défense du canada croit ce député
conservateur à bord du sous-marin
toutefois eric isabelle et son équipage
s'estime privilégié et préparent leur
prochaine mission cette année de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique et sinaï label dali
radio-canada au large d'halifax